good morning and thank you all for being
here but a special thank you to the
men and women fighting the fires our
first responders
our volunteers our local leaders
law enforcement everybody that is
helping so much to
get what i handled weekend on the calder
fire and we appreciate all their uh
assistance and efforts and
and uh contributions we just finished a
briefing with representatives across the
state government
and our federal delegation uh
congressman amedoy who's with us emma
day i apologize representatives from
senator rosen senator cortez mask those
with us along with local leaders i want
to thank them for their leadership
on this
effort that we're putting forward
we are using all of our resources
everything we have at our disposal and
coordinating closely with cal fire the
lead for the calder fire to ensure that
the health and safety of all of our
residents protect structures including
homes and businesses
and our beautiful lake tahoe
i am pressed that the progress that's
been made just in the last 24 hours
since i issued a declaration of
emergency
because of the advanced planning and
preparation by the nevada division of
emergency management
and the nevada division of forestry the
nevada department of transportation and
so many other state and federal agencies
the declaration allowed us to move
forward quickly including
mobilizing the national guard i want to
have a special shout out to general
barry for his assistance in making that
such a smooth transition and once again
the guard has stepped up every single
time we've asked something of them
they're the first ones to help
i've asked some of our subject matter
experts to join me here today to provide
additional updates and answers and
questions that you might have
at this time i'd like to turn the
program over to john vockendall
emergency management program manager for
the nevada division of emergency
management to provide an update and help
introduce some of our other speakers
john thank you
welcome everybody to the state emergency
operations center i want to thank you
for coming and listening to our story we
started preparation for this over 10
days ago in coordination with california
fire california office of emergency
services as well as the imt that was
helping coordinate the fire operations
when we started that we immediately
implemented our emergency support
functions and to coordinate advanced
planning for the evacuation efforts and
for backup fire resources to this region
because they've been stripped
dramatically over the last couple months
with all of the fires that have happened
on the california nevada
forestry service so over the last week
ndot has developed and formulated a plan
that's been released and was utilized
yesterday for the successful evacuation
of the california side of the south lake
tahoe community and we're hoping to
continue to use that plan to move
forward as we look into the potential
actions on the nevada side as the fire
moves
we also spent a lot of time in the last
week coordinating with the american red
cross in the efforts of opening up
evacuation shelters in douglas county
carson city and washoe county three of
which are currently completely full at
capacity and more being opened up
including a large shelter in washoe
county
we have a number of fire resources that
have come in to backfill the sierra
front region here because their
resources are on the fire so we have
clark county has sent up a task force
consisting of their forces north las
vegas and the parum agencies and then we
also have resources coming from elko
county to backfill the area
law enforcement has been coordinated for
the last week to assist nevada highway
patrol as well as the other dps agencies
in an effort to control the evacuation
effort for a safe and productive egress
out of the lake
currently ndf has a number of resources
they're going to speak to those
specifically our law enforcement
agencies have been the nevada highway
patrol the state fire marshal's office
the washoe county sheriff's office the
douglas county sheriff's office and then
carson city sheriff's office
successfully doing the evacuation
yesterday
we've been coordinating with the
governor's office of energy and the
department of agriculture in the fuel
monitoring in the area to make sure
there's plenty of fuel for the evacuees
as they come into our area the
department of agriculture is also
monitoring the grocery stores and the
food on the shelves to make sure as
people enter the areas we have enough
resources
we do have liaison officers people from
our agency and local agencies here in
nevada embedded both in the california
office of emergency services soc their
operations center as well as the
incident command post in el dorado
county
they in turn have liaison officers
embedded with us the national guard from
california has one over here with our
national guard we have a health and
human services as well as a cal oes
liaison officer embedded with us from
state resources and then from the local
resources douglas county and carson city
both have deputies embedded with us so
we can quickly pull the action point to
make evacuations happen when needed i'm
going to turn it over to major general
barry to update on the national guard
thank you john and uh andre berry the
adjunct general for the state of nevada
i also want to thank the governor again
because of his actions we were able to
get on top of getting our resources
activated as soon as possible
this is really a whole of government
approach in terms of bringing the
resources around the state federal state
and local levels so working together is
really critical for an incident like
this and we'll be together through the
end this is a perfect example of us as a
guard unit protecting our homeland but
also neighbors helping neighbors uh
currently for the nevada national guard
we have 55 personnel who are currently
working on state active duty working
multiple shifts we can double or triple
that if we have to and make more
available if needed our missions right
now are traffic control in support of
the evacuations
two helicopters have been activated and
one mass unit modular airborne
firefighting system of our c-130s are we
are fully integrated with the emergency
operations centers and the california
air national guard
doing traffic control points in south
lake tahoe at this time on the 50
corridor our joint operations center is
going 24 7 and will be up as long as as
needed and we are available to work with
with the supporting agencies the nevada
national guard is going to be engaged in
this process as long as we need to we
appreciate the support of the other
agencies and we're available to work
this incident all the way through at
this time i'm going to turn over to the
ndf divided division of forestry mr john
christopherson to give some updates
thank you
good morning uh my name is john
christopherson i'm the deputy
administrator with the nevada division
of forestry
and i'd just like to start by uh saying
what a tragic event that we're all
dealing with here today and we're sorry
when we consider all the loss for for
individuals that this was created
we thank all the firefighting and law
enforcement and other first responder
assets for for their engagement in this
effort and we hope that they're able to
remain safe throughout the duration of
this incident
the division of forestry as well as many
other uh state federal and local
government agencies have been
planning training and preparing for
events like this uh continuously this is
not something that catches us by
surprise as we
heard from john back at all today with
emergency management we all work
together uh to coordinate and share our
efforts to make sure that we have a
comprehensive and holistic uh response
to these kind of incidents
the division of forestry has committed
multiple of our multiple assets of ours
the uh
we have five type three engines
committed to the incident we have 24 20
person hand crews uh
assigned to the incident we're
supporting the national guard's two
helicopters that are flying on the
incident by supplying helicopter
managers for their mission
and overall we have 130 staff assigned
to this fire and additional overhead
functioning as liaisons to the incident
additionally we've got uh three uh
10-person crews with two other 10-person
crews on their way to uh to support the
incident uh through
managing vegetation out ahead of the
fire working with nv energy to
prioritize and identify line clearance
and other areas where vegetation can be
managed uh such that it will not burn as
intensely and hopefully serve as some
sort of
barrier and perhaps a
situation where control on the fire will
be more effectively instituted
we're looking at the feasibility of
moving over a mobile kitchen from our
wells office in order to feed some of
these uh
resources that are working on the fire
and we
also
have on contract which we just i guess
got released from the state of
washington two super scoopers uh those
are the airplanes that we've seen on the
news that fly in scoop water out of the
lakes or other water sources and dump
the water on the fire they have we are
working with cal fire now who is the
incident manager for the cal door
incident to get those incidents deployed
on the fire or those resources deployed
on the fire
lake tahoe i mean really is a national
model for effective collaboration
between agencies much of that
cooperation occurs in the area of
wildland fire fuel management
and to date from counting back to
say 19 20 20 years ago
2000
from 2000 to 2020
we've traded over 31 000 acres of
hazardous fuels on the nevada side of
the base and that's federal government
state government and local government
as this fire and many others
continuously show there's a lot more
that needs to be done a whole lot more
uh
only two fires in the recorded history
across the sierra from the east to the
west or from west to the east and both
of those fires have occurred this year
so this seems to be something like the
new norm these these kind of incidents
are something that we're going to be
continually faced with and have to
prepare and effectively deal with
there's a need for more aggressive
forest management out there on the
landscape an increase in the pace and
the scale of our work in order to us
create more sustainable forest
conditions out on the landscape and that
is what our agency is an advocate for
and we will continually
work towards with ourselves and our
partners through the
shared stewardship agreement in order to
effectively create a condition that
leads to safety for our state's
population as well as our natural
resources
thank you
i think you will be able to take some
questions for the governor and some of
our subject matter experts we have yeah
i'm curious you said you spoke to the
congressional delegation a few minutes
ago what did you ask for and what did
they offer
well we just you know spoke to the
everyone's cooperation this is a joint
effort and i think uh it was a
conversation that we made it clear that
to fight this fire we're going to use
every state resource possible uh both
representative ammaday and senator
cortez master made it clear that they
will do anything they possibly can i
will do anything i possibly can and in
terms of outreach other governors it
just was a collaboration of resources
and efforts in a similar vein have you
spoken to newsome at all and said what
gives why
have spoke to governor newsom i called
him and he's called me we spoke a couple
times uh
it wasn't what gives it's okay we've got
a problem on our hands we're gonna deal
with it as best as possible we have a
good relationship in terms of our mutual
aid agreements and we're going to fight
this together
yesterday cal fire announced they were
bringing in the military
i assume that's other than the national
guard and does that will that flow over
into the state of nevada and do you have
any idea what they would do
i can't speak specifically to the
military if we uh we're going to use
every asset we have general i don't know
if you have any comments as it relates
to that to military active duty to bring
them in as related to that but we will
employ any resources available just for
the purposes of nevada uh i told you the
number that we're activated 55 right now
and we could ramp up if we have to
uh we're going to take care of nevada
right now we don't have an agreement at
this time we do have a liaison working
in our office from california so if the
need be and if we needed additional
assistance we have an e-mac agreements
that we can work through but at this
time there is no need to have additional
military personnel from california we're
okay if the governor says or we get some
uh questions in terms of giving some
additional resources we can work through
that but right now we're okay in terms
of military personnel for nevada
thank you other questions
i was wondering if you could talk about
the scope of the response i saw that
some crews were going to incline village
uh i'm curious you know how far the
crews are being deployed and
where around the world are you talking
about is the specific deployment of the
assets that we're using now
thank you for the question i failed to
spell my name because it's not common
spelling last name is b is in bravo a
k k
e is an echo d is in delta a h l first
name is j-o-n john
so on that question we are planning days
and up to weeks ahead to make sure we
have a coordinated response we don't
want to be playing catch-up and not have
the resources in place so the effort
that started over a week ago about 10
days ago of reaching out across our
entire state for all available resources
not only from the local government but
from the federal agencies to see what
they could help bring to the area to
help support so we have all of the local
resources not only on this fire they
came off the tamarack fire they've come
off the dixie fire so they're constantly
jumping from fire to fire so we've
reached out regionally across the entire
state to bring in resources and because
we've done that we're back filling those
stations around the lake because they
are stripped they've sent their
resources for immediate life safety now
we want to put that second layer in
place for life safety property
preservation as well as safely
evacuating people
can somebody whoever wants to answer
what is your biggest concern today
protecting you know our structures our
assets
and first and foremost the people in the
state and the nevada and also those in
california
is there a game plan for when we see
that
evacuation move to the nevada side
well
i think that douglas county was here
earlier they would be ones making the
call in terms of a
mandatory evacuation and we will work
through the details of the evacuation as
we move forward we've already started i
was impressed with the first group of
folks coming out of
the tahoe area and we're going to
continue
do we know when we should see the fire
move to the nevada side
we're hopeful that it doesn't move but
you know uh somebody want to address
that one
we don't have a timeline these are not
predictable for that
that's correct thank you governor so
it's called wildland fire for a reason
it acts wild so our initial estimates
was it could go this way or it could go
this way or it could go this way it
moved to all three when the winds picked
up over the weekend and we are in a red
flag morning through tomorrow
so the estimate we don't have a timeline
we are preparing for worst case scenario
and getting people out of the area
i think we've got time for a couple more
we're in the midst of a pandemic you
know what are the mitigation efforts
within the
evacuation centers what are we doing
we are continuing our coveted mitigation
efforts for encouraging everyone to get
vaccinated this is another reason to
protect these first responders and the
people on the front lines
the
evacuation centers will be complying
with the directives that have been
issued by the state regarding warring
mess
did you personally go up to the fire
lines or no we have a visit planned this
afternoon i wonder what the status of
the casinos are are they being used as
command centers are they being asked we
had chairman gibson was also in the
meeting we had we just wrapped up with
two of them i believe are being used as
evacuation
sites for folks to go to uh they're
still operational as of this minute but
we're playing that on an hour-by-hour
basis as well
usually in times like this is when the
scammers come out can you think of
anything right now that people need to
be aware of um you know i don't know
fire repair places or any of those types
of things
and that's a good question i think
that'll probably come a little bit later
after we get through this
uh the thing i want people to be aware
of is their neighbors i mean if you
haven't reached out to your neighbors uh
and you're in this area please do so i
mean to make sure that they're okay uh
you saw this happen in louisiana you're
seeing it happen here some people are
just reluctant to leave their home uh so
encourage those that you know that live
in the evacuated areas that follow the
evacuation orders and everybody be safe
as a result of that but we haven't had
any scams thus far
price gouging is always an issue when
you talk about evacuations is that
something on your radar at this point or
are you considering an executive order
well price gouging is always an issue
when it comes to an emergency whether
that related to colbit we saw price
gouging with water and toilet paper
during covet you know
and hand sanitizer uh we're aware that
we hope that
good merchants are not going to partake
in price couching they're going to
partake in trying to make their goods
available for the widest group of people
they possibly can we haven't seen that
this yet but our eyes are open following
that we'll do one more
i want to just emphasize the severity of
the fire you can see i'm standing here
and i'm getting all ash particulates on
my jacket even the black jacket shows up
so you can see you see him on your black
shirt the same thing
uh
this is serious folks this is extremely
serious we ask everyone to stay in tune
to stay aware of what the best practices
are and to follow our emergency
management group so that we can get
people out safety safely rather protect
as many assets as we possibly can and
again i cannot begin to thank the men
and women of the national guard our
firefighters on the front line
our law enforcement our first responders
our health care workers everybody that's
associated with the response the people
that are stocking the grocery store
shelves that people are providing food
everybody that's associated with this is
has done a great job and just shows you
that we as nevadans step up when our
neighbor needs help
all right thank you everyone for coming
out
sorry
one more question um it's up to me
okay go ahead uh
you know the press really said that you
anticipated the fire coming to the
nevada side and i i know that these
wildland fires are hard to predict but
i'm wondering where
you anticipate that what information
that's based off where in the front that
might occur okay i can't address this
specifically where it would be coming
across if it when it does come across i
don't know if you want to take a stab at
that if you're done or you want to
thank you sir
so best estimates are to stay inside of
the tahoe basin and wrap around the
basin both heading north around the west
side and north around the east side when
the winds pick up it's wild it changes
everything so we're playing all
estimates all best guesses as to how and
when and where it's going to move around
the lake if it does and how when and
where it's going to leave from the lake
we have contingency plans for every one
of those areas and resources available
to manage it thanks
all right thank you everyone